[Music]
pleased to say annabelle
joins me now good morning to you uh you
play beautifully
but why do you think you were being held
back because you're a woman
um i mean it started off like ago
two or maybe two years a year and a half
two years ago
and um i would just send my music into
different production companies and
things and
they wouldn't get back they wouldn't
even say no they wouldn't listen to it
and i thought maybe it's just that's
just the music business um
and then um i kept kind of having
different comments thrown at me and it
seemed to be
a little bit kind of uh sexist actually
about women and things
um and uh what were some of the what
were some of the comments
so one man said i mean this was the main
one actually um
somebody up in the music business said
to me um
no offense and i think it's about my age
as well
and being a woman and he said no offense
but nobody really wants to listen
and look at a middle-aged woman playing
the piano
so i'd have comments like this you know
i just have comments going on like this
all the time and i just thought is it
because i'm a woman you know
and uh i ended up sending some stuff in
as annabelle and it didn't really get
much notice
and then i changed the name of
one of the pieces and then put it in as
arthur so i thought i'd come up with
this pseudonym just see what happens i
didn't really think much of it i thought
i'll just try
as a man and the response was ridiculous
it was just suddenly just
it went up there um from suddenly being
annabelle it was kind of i had just had
a lot more attention
um in general as arthur
so arthur parker actually got you heard
i mean
it's incredible i mean the the story you
account of being told nobody wants to to
listen to a middle-aged woman absolutely
horrific
i mean it shouldn't be happening in this
day and age really it's just i just
didn't think it would
i didn't i mean you know i think things
have got to change really i mean it's
starting to change but not enough really
before your little experiment with the
name were you aware
that that sexism was such a problem in
the music industry
no i mean i did my dad was a musician he
did to be
fair he said a long time ago i mean he
died about eight years ago
and i really wanted to go into it and he
said
it's a really really difficult business
the music business
really difficult and he said but
actually being a woman
is even harder i mean i don't know how
he knew that because he's a man but he
kind of he must have had to experience
through some of his friends or something
like that you know
going in the music business you know
because he had female singers and things
and um i just thought actually i don't
believe that you know obviously
you know he was right what would you
think that the
the root of it is it simply that women
are just not
taken seriously yeah i mean
and there's quite a few experience where
women have been told that
they're fluffy the music's fluffy i've
been told that before as well have you
got any
serious music and actually probably the
best music i do is serious like dramatic
and i've been like we've got a
restaurant and uh
i've been i've used to play my music in
in the restaurant
and um you know some men would say oh
this is really nice you know it's really
good music
and then who wrote this and i'd say i
did
and some of them were quite um i suppose
dramatic and they say you sure you wrote
this it's quite masculine so
it was just like an overall thing i mean
it must be infuriating so annoying isn't
it
well i just didn't think i just didn't
think it was like that nowadays you know
i think
i just i mean the amount of comments
since this has come up
and it's been in the media i mean the
amount of comments i've had from women
and they're also in my industry like
they said you're so right i mean this
really you know and men will say oh
she's attention seeking she's this and
that but actually i'm not i'm just
trying to get my music out there
and it's sad really that i've had to
actually use a man's name to get
out there and notice really it shouldn't
be like that yeah indeed what sort of
response have you had on uh social media
when when you put out your story um
well from women it's been fantastic
i've had so many comments and positive
comments and it's actually made them
want to send their stuff out and you
know
so that's good that's a good thing um
there was
one write-up and you know when they have
the comments underneath
um there was quite a few ones from males
and they say things like well she looks
like her man so it's all about again
what i looked like it wasn't about the
music and the story and everything like
that was all
literally what i looked like what advice
would you
then give to um women wanting to to
get into music or young men when
thinking about this as a career what
would you say to them
i just think just don't give up i mean
you know don't listen to
um comments from men don't just if you
think you're good enough if you think
you've got a chance
just don't give up just keep sending it
in sending it in and just
you know hopefully you know i might have
changed a few
women's life there might be a few women
like um not sending their stuff out
because they've had
bad response from males and things so i
think just don't give up just keep doing
it because
you know good message good message of
encouragement there annabelle bennett
thank you very much
thank you very much thank you